marie rocco siffredi d'être avec nom
puisqu'il ya le lancement dès votre site
internet sur le kama sutra aujourd'hui
c'est là c'est sensé aujourd'hui c'est
soft mais faut rappeler que c'est un
site pour adultes interdits aux moins de
18 ans c'est à dire qu'il y en a plein
ici qui ne peuvent pas y aller pour le
clou il ya les corps non mais non métier
mais c'est vraiment récente s'échauffent
tombés d'accord très très soft c'est à
dire c'est sa soeur jumelle est en
permanence et l'espérance rennes 2 30e
et passe années de boulot avant au moins
une position par an les prix bien faire
simplement la position en elle-même bien
chiant c'est avec qui tu va la faire
comme la faire savoir qu'on me tue émis
comme la fille l ennemi on peut pas tout
faire avec tout le monde
elles se présentent sur balles si on
fait pas les mêmes choses avec une bd
avec une barre c'est pour ça que ça
s'appelle s'il y en a qui lancent des
parfois tu danses des années
l'opposition chacun voit midi à sa porte
mais ça très bien quelle gabardine de
rocco il permet par contre j'ai une
question à vous avez très vite lever le
doigt
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non aucun rapport mais j'avais une
question je voulais savoir vous dites
que faut pas reproduire parce que c'est
vos positions à vous mais des questions
se passe jamais dit ça je me dis il faut
pas l'oeuvre produite jeudi pour
s'adapter avec les personnages non il
faut faire très attention quand on
reproduit des pussycat massif va
dépendre caumont et me mary
mais un lieu éphémère cément si on prend
les mauvaises habitudes passées comme le
tennis tu commences à malte et on verra
c'est pas et tu te retrouves dix ans
après ne s'est toujours pas jouer bas
c'est pas quelqu'un assis mais c'est
aussi pas seulement que des potions
c'est la façon de le faire bien sûr très
important c'est la façon de de
l'expérimenté avec le partenaire pour
arriver à voir le maximum de la
sexualité
bah de toute façon tout à l'heure quand
vous êtes rentrée ouf je viens de
terminer un film avec les hôtesses de
l'air 50
eh oui
flaesch vous avez choisi quelle
compagnie interlangues eu ce genre fait
j'ai toujours le temps pour changer les
titres j'aime bien votre tête et bat
c'est pour toi c'est qu'à des deux toi
plaisir